[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
plane gerade die baby shower party für
meine beste freundin nadja die ten der
alle mit ihr war ich damals bei den top
torjägern und auch so habt ihr die nadja
immer mal wieder gesehen und sie bekommt
ein baby endlich endlich werde ich tante
und ja sie bekommen ein baby shower
party von mir damals hat sie meine party
organisiert und jetzt auch wenn ich sehe
ich eine party für sie
und in diesem video möchte ich einfach
tipps und tricks geben und zeigen wie
ihr eine party organisieren könnt ohne
dass hier in stress kommt ohne das was
vergessen wird und dass einfach der tag
zu einem richtig schönen und
unvergesslichen tag wird ganz wichtig
dabei ist dass ihr euch to-do-listen
macht dass ihr zb immer auf dem handy
einen notizzettel habt wo ich dann immer
wieder was eintragen könnt wenn sich ein
feld bei mir ist es nämlich oftmals so
dass ich dann irgendwie gerade kurz vorm
schlafengehen bin und dann fällt mir
wieder was ein aber ich habe natürlich
dank ein notizzettel dabei also schreibe
ich es einfach als notiz in mein handy
und kannst dann später in die to do
liste eintragen was ich noch ganz
wichtig finde das ist echt ein guter
tipp nimmt auf jeden fall hilfe an das
heißt entweder hol dir den papa mit ins
boot oder ihr holt noch eine andere
freundin mit ins boot denn gemeinsam
planen und organisieren ist viel
einfacher und vor allem kann man sich da
gegenseitig unterstützen und dann
vergisst man eben auch nichts und jetzt
habe ich einfach so eine checkliste für
euch das heißt wir gehen jetzt von vorne
los und ich sage euch wie ich was
organisieren und planen und wie ihr es
auch eben richtig gut machen können
bei der baby shower party solltet ihr
euch auf jeden fall zuerst noch mal
überlegen wer kommt denn überhaupt ich
finde es ist eine kleine intime
veranstaltung das heißt am besten
einfach nur die engsten freundinnen von
der zu werdenden mama die papas und
männer würde ich das glaube ich
weglassen ich glaube die können wir zu
einer baby shower party recht wenig
anfangen und vor allem feiert man ja
auch einfach noch mal mit der mama
das heißt man sitzt noch mal schön
gemütlich zusammen die mama oder die
werdende mama kann eben noch mal mit
ihren freundinnen einen schönen tag
verbringen
denn nach der geburt hat man so schnell
erst mal keine zeit mehr dafür
von daher finde ich so am einfachsten
man macht einfach eine hortgruppe
eine einladungskarte verschicken finde
ich jetzt bei einer baby shower party
ein bisschen unnötig und überflüssig das
heißt einfach nur whatsapp gruppe machen
da kann man einen gemeinsamen termin
finden und vor allem kann man schauen
wer wann kommen kann
und falls es eben gäste gibt die zum
beispiel von weiter weg kommen wie eine
tante oder eine kussszene oder eine
freundin die weiter weg gezogen ist dann
schaut man eben auch gleich nach einer
übernachtungsmöglichkeit wer fährt mit
wem brauchen eine mitfahrgelegenheit und
vor allem kann man so alles gemeinsam
richtig von organisieren also im prinzip
ist es ein baby shower party ähnlich zu
einem junggesellenabschied da kommen
auch die engsten freundinnen und
entweder kündigt man es an oder man
überrascht eben die braut oder die zu
wertende mama und ich glaube es sind
auch so immer die engsten freunde die
man eben auch zur hochzeit einlädt und
eben auch die engsten freunde die man
dabei haben möchte wenn das baby auf der
welt ist ja nur ist man auf ein baby
shower party etwas brav und macht halt
nicht so party gefeiert man halt anders
weiß noch was ich meine wenn man eine
party feiert wo man eine einladungskarte
braucht dann sollte man einfach eine
einladungskarte machen wo eben auch
alles wichtige drauf steht das heißt so
was wie was wird gefeiert datum und
uhrzeit der ort wie komme ich dahin
dresscode und was kann ich mitbringen
aber das feld der ziel bei der baby
shower party und auch bei den
junggesellenabschied einfach auf so was
würde ich dann eher machen bei einem
geburtstag oder zum beispiel bei einer
hochzeit
der zweite wichtige punkt ist natürlich
der termin das heißt ihr solltet einen
termin finden an dem möglichst viele
freundinnen können am wochenende ist
meist am besten
und die mama muss natürlich auch zeit
haben den terminkalender bei der mama
herauszufinden ist ganz einfach entweder
über den ehemann über den partner oder
eben über die beste freundin jeweils
meist auch bescheid und dann am besten
direkt blocken also entweder einen
vorwand finden und sagen okay an dem tag
gehen wir zusammen frühstücken in einem
café oder du kommst zu mir oder man weit
die mama eben ein falls es doch nicht so
eine überraschungs maus ist und sagt an
diesem tag findet eine party statt
der dritte punkt ist das budget das
solltet ihr wirklich nicht aus den augen
verlieren
vor allem bei dem freundeskreis hat man
echt viele unterschiedliche personen die
einstudierten auch die andere arbeitet
schon die eine ist vielleicht noch
schülerin und das sollte man am anfang
wirklich offen damit umgehen
wer kann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
besteuern wäre ein bisschen weniger und
dann gibt es einfache tipps und tricks
wie auch viele dinge selber machen könnt
und wirklich auch geld sparen können da
komme ich aber später bei den einzelnen
punkten noch drauf zurück als nächstes
solltet ihr das motto plane gut motto
bei uns jetzt natürlich baby shower
party
es wird ein mädchen das wissen wir auch
schon ich weiß jetzt kommt wieder gender
roll und alles mögliche aber wir werden
eine rosa baby party feiern denn wir
sind alles mädchen und vermögen alle
rosa ja da entstehen immer diskussionen
ich weiß nicht warum aber ich bin halt
mädchen ich mag pink und ich mag große
und meine kinder lebens auch ich glaube
morath gefällt auch und ich glaube die
nadja freut sich da auch drüber
aber natürlich kann man die party so
machen wie man möchte man kann auch eine
blaue baby party machen für einen für
ein mädchen oder eine lila orange das
ist jedem selbst überlassen
aber unsere party die mit rosa weil wir
es mögen dann solltet ihr relativ früh
schon wissen wo feiern wir also wo ist
die location
jetzt könnt ihr zum beispiel so eine
party im restaurant feiern das heißt er
miete durch einen tisch viele
restaurants und cafés haben auch so ein
kleines abteil wo man einfach ein
bisschen privater ist ich finde im
restaurant ist es schön es kann auch
gemütlich sein aber man hat hat
natürlich immer viele menschen außen rum
das heißt viele andere gäste und
natürlich ist es auch eine kostenfrage
wenn man dort was ist entweder zum
frühstück oder zum abendessen ist auch
ein thema ganz günstig dann hat man noch
die möglichkeit ein vereinsheim zum
beispiel zu buchen sollen wie es früher
immer gemacht wenn wir während der
schulzeit lassen partys gefeiert haben
oder stufenpartys dann gibt es immer
irgendwo im verein wo man sich einmieten
kann
da gibt es genügend tische genügend
toiletten der harz genähten kühlschränke
wenn man also zu hause nicht die
möglichkeit hat zu feiern
dann kann man wirklich auch ein
vereinsheim gehen und wirklich dort
feiern ist auch relativ günstig oder es
bietet sich an bei jemandem zu hause zu
feiern wir haben einen schönen garten
wir haben auch ein großes wohn und
esszimmer
das heißt wir werden jetzt die party bei
uns zu hause machen
so fallen zuerst einmal die mietkosten
weg und man hat es natürlich richtig
gemütlich man kann feiern wann man
möchte es ist immer frei und es ist
einfach richtig schön also bei uns zu
hause ist es schön und gemütlich und
vielleicht habt ihr wirklich jemanden
dem freundeskreis wo ihr dann eben auch
feiern können
im restaurant hat man natürlich den
vorteil das essen ist da die getränke
sind da aber man hat auch den nachteil
dass man eben andere gäste stören kann
das heißt wenn man ein bisschen lautere
gruppe ist ist es oftmals für andere
gäste etwas störend wenn man dann das
ist und man kann irgendwie nicht so ganz
frei sein zuhause hat man den vorteil
ich kann ganz frei seien es in keiner
anderen gäste da ich habe meine eigene
location aber man muss natürlich auch
bedenken habe ich einen gruß an den
tisch der groß genug ist muss ich
vielleicht bierbänke besorgen einen
tisch besorgen kühlschränke besorgen
oder wenn man im garten feiert brauche
ich vielleicht noch eine sonnen
abdeckung also das sind einfach so dinge
entweder hat man weniger arbeit ist aber
öffentlich in den öffentlichen raum oder
man hat eben die arbeit zu hause ist
aber privat gemütlich und man muss eben
doch die dinge selber organisieren was
bei einer fahrt natürlich auch ganz
wichtig ist finde ich zumindest dass man
fotos und videos macht da kann man
entweder jemanden buchen und sagen okay
wir haben uns jetzt wird diesen tagen
fotografen gesucht oder jemand und der
ebenen video macht oder man spricht im
vorfeld schon mit den freundinnen und
sagt gut du und du ihr macht jetzt fotos
und videos oder wir kümmern uns
gemeinsam darum den ich finde oftmals
ist es so also bei uns zumindest wir
vergessen es dann einfach immer wir
feiern eine coole party wir sind mit
freunden zusammen und man genießt
einfach den augenblick aber keiner baby
shower finde ich es ganz schön wenn man
im nachgang daneben auch noch fotos aber
keine videoausschnitt an die man sich
erinnern kann und die man später auch
mal dem baby zeigen kann
deswegen sollte das finde ich schon
organisieren also schon sagen wer ist
dafür zuständig es gibt ja auch diese
einwegkameras die man dann auf den tisch
stellen kann werde ich auch immer ganz
witzig und da sollte man auf jeden fall
dran denken
essen und getränke wenn man außerhalb
feiert im restaurant fällt dieser punkt
natürlich weg wobei man da auch
überlegen kann den wir in ein restaurant
und wählen á la carte oder wählen wir
schon ein menü damit eben auch schneller
geht dann ist jeder das gleiche
das kann man sich natürlich auch
überlegen im vereinsheim kann man
entweder auch selbst was mitbringen man
kann dem vereinsheim was bestellen oder
zum beispiel einen lieferdienst wählen
oder ein catering zu hause hat man auch
die möglichkeit entweder kochen wir alle
selber haben natürlich auch die arbeit
aber man kann die arbeit ja auch ganz
gut aufteilen
wir wählen einen lieferdienst und können
zum beispiel pizza bestellen zu haben
was bei unsere freundin bei der lisa
gemacht war auch ganz cool
vor allem weil immer raus jemanden dabei
ist oder man wählt eben catering
catering ist natürlich so die teuerste
variante lieferdienste kommt direkt
danach ist etwas günstiger und selber
machen finde ich ist für alle am
günstigsten und vor allem kann jeder was
bei steuer wasser eben auch mag
wir werden jetzt bei der nation brunch
machen das heißt wir machen bei uns da
drüben das frühstück wir werden das
frühstücksbuffet richten die brötchen
holen und jeder bringt einfach ein
bisschen was mit dir ist die back die
buchteln oder macht ihre leckeren den
leckeren kuchen dann bringt andere
freundin in obstsalat mit die andere
bringt gemüsespieße mit und so kann man
sich wirklich auch in der waz- gruppe
absprechen
auf jeden fall eine liste machen damit
man auch sieht was noch fehlt und was
nicht fehlt das ist auch immer ganz
wichtig da fehlen dann meist die
banalsten sachen wie brötchen zum
beispiel bei kleiner dran gedacht hat
und wir machen jetzt einfach so
gerichten so das komplette frühstück und
jeder starter noch was dazu weil ja und
die torte die kommt natürlich später
eine baby shower party dient natürlich
auch dazu dass man der mama und papa
noch geschenk gemacht eben dinge die
fehlen und ich finde da immer ganz
wichtig dinge zu schenken die sie eben
auch noch brauchen also nicht
überflüssig ist weiß ja wie es ist nach
der geburt bekommt man viel kleidung
geschenkt man bekommt viele spielsachen
geschenkt und hat irgendwie schon das
zehnte kuschelt er aber das was dann
noch fehlt so was wie der wickeltisch
oder an maxi cosi in autos sitzt so
etwas fehlt dann meist noch und ich habe
jetzt einfach geschaut was fehlt
internat ja noch und wir sprechen da ja
auch als freundinnen darüber was
brauchen wir was brauchen wir nicht und
dann hab ich da tue jetzt mach mal
halblang kauft die nicht alles sofort
darfst du immer noch genügend zeit wenn
das baby da ist und das sind einfach
nicht so dinge die wir holen
also wir haben jetzt den stuhl geholt
den tripp trapp den teller eben auch
haben da noch den wickeltisch diese
wickelt kombination mit der badewanne
darunter die wirklich überall hin
gestellt werden kann und einfach noch so
ein paar kleine dinge da kann jeder
zusammenlegen sie hat nicht zehn
verschiedene geschenke sondern wirklich
nur das was ihr braucht und das sollte
man natürlich auch rechtzeitig besorgen
dann sollte man sich überlegen was er
denn das unterhaltungsprogramm möchte
man überhaupt sowas machen
es gab es auch gerade bei
junggesellenabschieden immer so das
thema machen wir spiele machen wir keine
spiele
ich meine wir sind alles erwachsene
frauen wir sind alle nicht mehr anfang
20 zumindest nicht mehr alle und wir
werden natürlich so ein bisschen was
richtung unterhaltung machen aber jetzt
keine banalen spiele also ja ich meine
jeder weiß schaut und das ist ein
mädchen wird und es gibt ja spieler auf
einer baby shower party wie wir schätzen
das gewicht wir tippen wann das baby zur
welt kommt das finde ich wiederum ganz
witzig das hat auch meine familie
gemacht da hatten wir in der ortsgruppe
so ein kleines tippspiel
das heißt jeder hat so ein termin
genannt wann kommt das baby zur welt bei
erwartet bei sanierer gab es damals noch
keine whatsapp zumindest nicht bei uns
und das finde ich ganz witzig was wir
bei nadja machen werden ich habe baby
bodys besorgt und stoff stifter diese
textil stifter und zuletzt ziehen und
die können wir dann einfach bemalen
lustige sprüche drauf schreiben gerade
für den dunhill für den papa dass er
einfach wenn das baby da man zieht immer
was lustige sagt immer was zu machen
ja das sind so dinge die wir machen
werde
oder die samira die bastelt gerade sie
macht karten eine baby karte wo jeder
darauf unterschreiben kann ich habe auch
ein gästebuch besorgt was wir noch
gestalten werden wo wir dann einfach am
anfang direkt was rein schreiben geht er
da ist auf der bwin party dann kann die
nadja später ein foto ein kleben und
dieses gästebuch nimmt sie dann mit nach
hause und dem wir dann jemand zuhause zu
besuch kommt also als baby gast darf
sich dann beantragen ein paar nette
wünsche schreiben oder einfach eine
botschaft an das baby dann wird da ein
foto noch mit eingeklebt und irgendwann
wenn es baby das kind dann alt genug ist
bekommt man dieses buch und kann dann
schauen wer mich alles besucht hat das
finde ich voll süß und da werden wir auf
der babyparty praktisch so den
startschuss machen und rein schreiben
und dann entsteht auch eine schöne
geschichte ja dass ich falls dies und
ich sage mir abbas gab noch die kärtchen
da schreiben wir dann sprüche drauf oder
einfach was schönes positiv ist wo die
nationen die einfach jeden tag sonst
hätte sehen können und dann steht da was
drauf und ich glaube das tut dann auch
immer ganz gut manchmal braucht man
einfach so ein bisschen positiven
zuspruch und dann geht der tag schon
richtig gut los und dann geht's schon an
die dekoration dekoration ist finde ich
ganz wichtig ich finde es macht einfach
schon mal so eine schöne positive
stimmung das heißt wir schauen jetzt
einfach mal wer hat noch was zu hause
gab bei uns im freundeskreis man
wirklich viele schon ein baby bekommen
und da hat jeder noch ein bisschen deko
zu hause von dem letzten
kindergeburtstag oder von der letzten
babyparty jeder steuer was bei und das
war es noch viel luftballons zum
beispiel oder zum tischläufer das holen
wir dann einfach dazu und dann können
wir alles wirklich schön dekorieren
der nächste punkt ist natürlich die
torte denn oder torte finde ich gibt
keine coole party für mich ist eine
party us bank komplett wenn es auch eine
schöne mode orte gibt die torte wird
natürlich backen und da kann man sich
eben überlegen ist jemand im
freundeskreis dabei der das backen kann
oder sollte man da jemanden fragen eine
bäckerei zum beispiel eine konditorei
oder irgendjemand bekannten der das eben
zu einem backen kann ja und so eine
richtig schöne motto torte das ist doch
was richtig coole im prinzip habt ihr
dann alle vorbereitungen erst einmal
getroffen dh es kann dann in richtung
baby party gehen und je früher ihr diese
vorbereitung trifft umso entspannter
wird macht euch die to-do-listen
sprecht mit euren freundinnen und dann
gehts zur party ich werde zu machen ich
werde zwei tage vor der partie mit der
torte beginnen je nachdem was wie eine
torte ihr macht müsst ihr vielleicht
auch schon früher beginnen falls eine
figur zum beispiel geformt wird die
torte wird also zwei tage vorher
gestellt und das zeige ich euch jetzt
aber was für eine torte ich machen werde
jetzt sind noch zwei tage bis zur party
und heute bereite ich schon mal die
torte v damit ich morgen einfach zeit
habe noch einkaufen zu gehen essen
vorzubereiten und eben alles andere was
noch ansteht die abc bereits einiges
vorbereitet gestern abend habe ich schon
den rührteig gemacht den wandel rührteig
damit mache ich ganz gerne motiv worden
weil der super saftig ist und jetzt hier
heute morgen habe ich schon die
buttercreme angesetzt und weil es gerade
bei uns ziemlich warm ist in der küche
war die butter bei raumtemperatur
einfach viel zu warm und ich konnte
nicht gut schlagen also habe ich einfach
tief gefrorene früchte genommen an die
schüssel gelegt und jetzt hat es
wirklich wunderbar gezeigt meine
freundin mag ganz gerne fruchtige torten
also habe ich auch schon eine frucht
anlage hergestellt drei stück um genau
zu sein und ihr könnt ihr wirklich auch
schon mehrere tage vorher herstellen
denn ihr könnt ihr nämlich ganz gut
einfrieren
so jetzt verbinde ich hier noch kurz die
buttercreme da habe ich jetzt eine
italienische buttercreme mit eiweiß und
dotter und die buttercreme für find ich
jetzt gleich noch mit etwas zitrone
passte
[Musik]
hiernach bisschen zitronen passte die
habe ich bereits auch schon im teig mit
dabei jetzt habe ich eine schöne
zitronencreme in den zitronen mandl teig
und eine erdbeer frucht einlage erdbeer
himbeer faktenlage ist einfach nur
zuhören und parallel arbeite ich gerade
sogar noch an meinem buch das heißt ich
werde jetzt hier zwischendrin immer mal
wieder auch torten fertig dekoriert
samira fotografierte gerade draußen
sarah bearbeitet schon andere bilder das
cover wird heute aus gemacht also hier
ist ordentlich was los bei uns jetzt
fühle ich die torte ganz einfach ich
gebe es immer ein bisschen buttercreme
auch den ersten boden verstreicht
da kommt dann die frucht einlage drauf
und der vorteil bei frucht einlagen ist
einfach sie halten wirklich super lange
das match nicht so durch und dadurch
dass sie gefahren sind wir die torte
gleich auch richtig schützt das heißt
ich kann sie auch viel schneller
bestreichen und ein komplett fertig
dekoriert
[Musik]
den schönsten boden den nehme ich immer
für oben auf das ist der boden von der
torte und dann macht ihr mal so eine
upside down technik das heißt so habe
ich einfach dem schönen geraten
abschluss und die torte wird gleich beim
bestreichen auch super schnell fest so
von innen heraus kühlt die dort jetzt
schon ganz gut weil ich eben die
gefrorenen frucht einlagen habe das
heißt kann jetzt hier schon mal die
erste schicht der buttercreme außen noch
auftragen
die torte kühl stellen und dann komplett
fertig einstreichen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die deko
herstellen
[Musik]
jetzt bereite ich auch gerade noch ein
rezept fürs buch vor rosa sachertorte
mit ruby schokolade und da mache ich
dann gleich noch eine resteverwertung
und stelle rocky road herr die sind auch
schön rosa das heißt das passt dann
perfekt auf unser buffet
[Musik]
dies so lecker richtig gut gehört jetzt
zu meinen lieblings trocken
[Musik]
die recaro sie sind echt aber ziemlich
cool denn ihr könnt alle reste
verbrauchen die ihr habt die schokolade
macht es noch paar trockenen zutaten wie
salz brezel erdnüsse marshmallows
getrocknete himbeeren und dann können
diese entweder in eine große form füll
und später einfach schneiden oder direkt
die kleine pralinen förmchen
[Musik]
brösel ich jetzt einfach nur ein paar
gefriergetrocknete hin wenn direkt in
die silikon form
so habe ich sie später nämlich auf der
oberfläche
[Musik]
so macht es so super
und jetzt können wir ich mich um das
torten motiv das soll einfach süß hat
teddybär werden der aber nicht 3d
geformt wird den 3d figuren die müsst
ihr wirklich ein paar tage vorher schon
machen
der wert so zweidimensional auf die
torte an den rand draufgelegt die habe
ich schon die höhe der torte gemessen
maly ziehe mein motiv aus und das ist
auch eine richtig coole schablone
technik und da könnt ihr euch entweder
ich bin selber malen oder ausdrucken
[Musik]
jesus der teddybär hier in der folie und
ich kann jetzt ganz einfach mit von land
arbeiten damit er von land etwas fester
wird möchte ich jetzt hier von dort und
blüten passte
dadurch hätte der teddy nämlich auch ein
bisschen aus ich habe sie einfach den
schoko von land weißer blüten passte und
dann habe ich ein schönes helles teddy
braun die folie fertig jetzt hier ein
bisschen mit kokosöl ein zuerst warum
ich jetzt den körper klickt einfach auf
die schablone drauf und drückt den
körper auch schön flach jetzt einfach
hinten anfangen das heißt alles was
hinter dem bauch und hinter dem körper
ist muss es zuerst geformt werden und
auch dahinter gelegt werden
so gefällt mit der teddy schon mal ganz
gut jetzt bekommt er aber noch struktur
dafür nehme ich jetzt hier einfach eine
kleine stern töne und werde die
oberfläche so ein bisschen an rauen wie
bei so viel lob
und hier im ort drücke ich jetzt ein
ball rein so bekommen es einfach noch
ein bisschen mehr tiefe
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt noch ein kleineres
stück daraus vor mich jetzt die schnauze
also einfach einen kreis diesen flach
drücken und ankleben
jetzt erkennt man dass es ein teddy wird
und von dem hell kommt jetzt noch ein
bisschen was in die ohren ein und
schmalz und dann mit dem bold wohl
bisher rein drücken
und hier drücke ich jetzt noch die augen
ein und da kommen doch zwei schwarze
kugel rein
der teddy bekommen jetzt noch rosa
wangen mit lebensmittel pulver farbe
dann ist der teddy fertig und ich kann
mich um die übrigen dekoration kümmern
da mach ich jetzt noch eine wimpelkette
sie habe ich jetzt weisen von dann mit
blöden pasta gemischt damit eben auch
wieder schnell trocknet jetzt kann ich
sie auf becker stärke ausrollen richtig
schön dünn
für die fähnchen nehme ich jetzt die
quadratischen ausstecher und für die
buchstaben habe ich buchstaben
ausstecher ich schreibe jetzt den namen
vom kind raus da müsst ihr aber auf
jeden fall nachfragen ob es okay ist ob
die eltern den namen verraten oder nicht
ich habe zwar ein paar danach gefragt es
ist okay also darf ich darauf schreiben
ich stelle jetzt hier zuerst einmal
quadrate aus und daraus schneide ich
dann eben die dreiecke da auf jeden fall
schauen dass der buchstabe draufpasst so
passt er perfekt jetzt kann ich hier die
fähnchen zu schneiden einfach von der
ecke bis zur mitte
das nehme ich ein bisschen rosa
verpasste kann einen teil rosa farben
ausrollen und dann die buchstaben
ausstechen
ich lebe ich noch die buchstaben an den
fähnchen fest und male dann mit dieser
goldenen sprühfarbe noch an dem goldrand
drauf und das mache ich dann immer so
dass ich die sprühfarbe einfach in den
deckel einsprühen einem pinsel nehme und
dann kann ich schöne feine striche
ziehen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich noch ein bisschen weiß
etwas rosa und darauf freue mich jetzt
die luftballons dafür erst mal eine
kugel herrschte dann einen tropfen
formen entstehen dann direkt hier drauf
flach drücken nicht ganz flach sondern
so dass er wirklich so ein bisschen noch
dreidimensional aussieht und einen teil
der weißen beförderungs lasse ich weiß
und den anderen teil besprühten
goldunternehmen ihr euch hier noch einen
kleinen rest und geformt unten noch das
endstück hier lasse jetzt alles an
trocknen und kann in der zwischenzeit
die torte komplett streichen und dann
mit hofer vom 10
[Musik]
elfriede modelliermasse drücke ich jetzt
noch in silikon förmchen rein
so kann ich nämlich schöne knöpfe formen
[Musik]
für den von darüber zog nehme ich jetzt
drei päckchen rosa und ein päckchen weiß
damit das rosa einfach nicht zu dunkel
wird das habe ich ein zartes babyrosa
aber jetzt kann ich denn von dort aus
rollen und dann startet damit einkleiden
[Musik]
die tat habe ich jetzt schon umgesetzt
auf eine große tortenplatte jetzt
bestreite ich hier den rand mit s-bahn
kleber und klebe dann einen fondant band
darauf dass rolle ich jetzt hier auf
einem holzstab auf dann gehts bisschen
einfacher
[Musik]
so bekommt man einen richtig schönen
sauberen abschluss hin
und jetzt kann ich die zarte dekorieren
das heißt zuerst einmal bringe ich den
teddy bear man ganz vorsichtig und ich
mache es jetzt in zwei teilen
das hat echt praktisch mit dem flachen
teddybären
denn der trockenen einfach super schnell
und ihr könnt wirklich innerhalb von
einem halben tag eine komplette torte
nicht dekorieren
da jetzt noch die luftballons zu leben
ganz dünn mit kleber bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt passt hier noch die wimpelkette
fertig ursprünglich wollte ich sie
eigentlich an den rand der torte kleben
da ist aber zu wenig platz also kommen
sie auf die torte drauf so eine richtige
wimpelkette ich habe zwei strohhalme in
gold damit bereits jeweils ein loch
reingemacht
ich habe ich noch einen faden und die
getrockneten buchstaben auf dem fähnchen
kommen hier rechts und links löcher rein
jetzt fehle ich das hier so durch immer
so dass der faden hinter dem buchstaben
ist
und jetzt nämlich hier goldene zucker
schrift und mal jetzt noch die schnur an
die luftballons
[Musik]
jetzt stehe ich hier den faden in das
röhrchen rein und entweder lassen dann
auf der anderen seite wieder raus und
macht den knoten oder ihr zieht ihn hier
oben raus macht den knoten und dann
könnte ihn nämlich verschwinden lassen
dass man den knoten rein und dicken
knoten und den nicht so weit wie möglich
hier nach unten schieben jetzt kann ich
den faden hier abschneiden und den
knoten in strohhalm verschwinden lassen
[Musik]
sofia jetzt kann ich sie aber pro
behalten
und je enger die stäbe zusammengehen um
so durch gebogener ist es und je weiter
sie auseinander gehen umso
durchgestreckt ist und damit die schönen
stabil halten stecke ich jetzt hier
zahnstocher bzw schachspieler rhein ganz
lange die kann ich nämlich bis ganz nach
unten durch stecken und dann die
geblockte drauf anbringen bis zum
verzehr lege ich die aber wieder weg und
steckt sie dann erst kurz vor dem
servieren wieder drauf und wenn ja wie
gesagt das nicht ausbluten passte machen
wollt könnt ihr auch einfach papier
nehmen das papier einfach so ein
doppeltes dreieck zu schneiden die
buchstaben drauf schreiben und über der
kette zusammenklappen das geht noch
einfacher sogar das habe ich jetzt
fertig das heißt ja bisher noch meine
knöpfchen und die herzchen die verteile
ich jetzt hier vielleicht noch auf der
torte vielleicht auch nicht noch machen
oder nicht was sagt ihr
ich bin zwar eigentlich muss ich las die
knöpfchen weg und streuen und herzchen
drauf denn oftmals ist weniger mehr
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte fertig wir machen
gerade noch fotos mit samira und ich bin
sogar echt gut in meinem zeitplan
das heißt ich kann jetzt mich noch
hinsetzen und noch eine playlist machen
für die musik musik ist nämlich auch
immer ganz wichtig und morgen habe ich
dann noch einen freien tag da kann ich
dann auch einkäufe erledigen getränke
holen lebensmittel holen die noch fehlen
kann doch ein bisschen deko besorgen das
reicht einfach so er es nach speyer und
dann ist übermorgen schon die partie
bereit
ich glaube das reicht an den kopf des
opfers
[Musik]
die torte gebacken die musik lister ist
erstellt einen tag vor der party oder
auch zwei tage vorher können wir nämlich
noch einkaufen gehen das heißt getränke
besorgen lebensmittel besorgen die noch
viel übrige deko besorgung ich werde
jetzt noch zu ihres fahren und wer doch
noch ein paar kleinigkeiten holen vor
allem und art déco teile und morgen
findet bei uns die party statt das heißt
morgen früh macht kommen dann alle
freundinnen und helfen mit beim aufbau
das ist auch immer ganz wichtig dass da
alle mit dabei sind dann braucht man
nicht so viel zeit und vor allem hat
jeder noch eine tolle idee und die nati
wird am morgen so kurz nach zehn kommen
10 15 zum frühstück und dann werden wir
schon feiern was ihr auch nicht
vergessen dürfe was passiert danach das
heißt danach sollten vielleicht noch
zwei drei freundinnen da seien die eben
auch mit aufräumen helfen die nadja
natürlich nicht also die zur
überraschenden person die das natürlich
nach hause gehen sie hat einen schönen
tag hoffentlich und die anderen
freundinnen räumen da noch mit auf dem
rad macht das ja auch immer ganz gerne
ich glaube da kommt dann wieder zurück
mit einem staubsauger und wird dann auf
jeden fall uns helfen sauber zu machen
und dann könnt ihr wenn ihr immer wieder
die gleiche clique seit die zusammen
feiert auch so eine kleine feedback
runde machen das heißt was war toll was
wir vielleicht nicht so toll was kann
man besser organisieren und dann denke
ich habe dir auf jeden fall immer eine
schöne feier
das war jetzt meine checkliste und wenn
ihr anhand dieser checkliste eure
nächste party plant denke ich wird zum
riesenerfolg und ihr werdet alle einen
schönen tag haben
ich freue mich jetzt schon auf die
partie morgen die liste findet ihr zum
download auf salehs - blog.de und falls
ihr videos dieser art öfter sehen wollt
schreibt gerne einfach in die kommentare
jetzt ging es ja praktisch nicht nur um
die torte sondern auch um die
organisation und um die planung und ich
mache sowas wirklich gerne falls sie da
noch weitere tipps und tricks von mir
haben wollen schreibt einfach rein
wir werden morgen hoffentlich einen
richtig schönen tag haben und ich zeige
euch einfach ein paar bilder von der
party also bis bald
jetzt holen wir hier bei der er ist
einfach nicht weg also wenn man sie
jetzt überlegt schälchen die kann man
sowieso immer gebrauchen
die brauchen wir danach auch noch gern
hier wohl was hast du nach lichterkette
in rosa max mehr auf dinge die man immer
braucht gott mit dem vogel super oder
richtig schön perfekt gerade alles noch
parallel alles mit vorbereitet nicht mal
nach vorn
[Musik]
jetzt aber alles bereits die nadja
komplexer leckeres frühstücksbuffet
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
alles
[Musik]
trau mich gar nicht so schön aus für die
bereit
[Musik]
art